maybe your team has already been knocked
out of the playoffs say your quarterback
was picked off on the last play of the
game or worse
maybe your quarterback inexplicably ran
a draw with 15 seconds left in the game
and no timeouts effectively crushing
your soul and will deliver but even if
your team's out of the playoffs
i'm sorry i'm sorry i'm back uh even if
your team is out of the playoffs it can
still be an ex exciting time to watch
and perhaps bet on games jason mccormick
from station casinos joins us jason i
apologize just went out of control there
foreign get you some popcorn hopefully
she brings you guys popcorn
this is an exciting time for the sports
books obviously with the super bowl
being the
weekend of the year for sports books but
you were saying this weekend too is also
a big weekend yeah you talk about super
bowl march madness but the conference
championships next week in the
divisional playoffs these are the top
weeks of the year for sportsbooks and i
always find it fascinating that the
sports books are always so close to
getting it right when it comes to the
spread and yet it's not an exact science
well we weren't right last week the
favorites went five and one and the
public did really really well a lot of
blowout games um in the wild card
weekend and this week the the spreads
are a little bit tighter
and we'll see how they do this week but
hopefully we get some of the dogs to
come in this week as the sports books
kind of got their butts kicked last week
but it's not some sort of crazy
algorithm it's it's guys sitting in the
room going what do you think yeah again
that's what that's what we do and what
our teams do is kind of crunch the
numbers to put up what we think is going
to generate two-way two-way action um
and sportsbooks all over town will have
different numbers so you gotta kind of
shop those numbers and it's not just the
the games it's the totals it's the first
half there's a ton of props that are
going to be put up so you got a lot of
different stuff to bet on and it becomes
even easier to put a few bucks on a game
because you have the mobile app now yeah
with our stn sports mobile app and the
mobile apps available that's just
absolutely incredible you don't have to
get come down to the book you don't have
to fight the lines there sign up in the
for the mobile app takes less than five
minutes and now you're betting sports
from the comfort of your home and not
just on football but you get the mma and
basketball and as we roll into that big
game you'll be able to get that action
and all the props that we have there as
well and right now you are i think uh
closer to the super bowl you're throwing
in some bonus bucks right yeah we've got
some bonus going going on right now you
get 100 bonus for all new signups you're
actually going to start seeing those
super bowl props start on our app
already um so if there's you know build
up to the game and excited about all the
things that we're offering on these
games this weekend as well are there any
crazy props out there right now already
that's always kind of fun well again in
nevada we do a lot of the stuff that
takes place on the field and a lot of
the offshore bets is where you're going
to find the gatorade color or how long
the national lamps are going to take we
don't offer those here but do a lot of
fun props and it always starts off with
you know is the coin toss going to be
heads or tails so uh you know from soup
to nuts we're gonna have all the props
that you can think of on the big game at
least that one's 50 50 right
so uh in the meantime this weekend what
do you what are some good bets and i
know that there's never a sure thing but
what are some things that you could be
looking at some interesting facts and
figures as we look at the games we talk
about cincinnati and tennessee the first
game that's going to kick off uh mike
grebel is a 4-0 in his time as the coach
of the titans coming off of a bye week
they're only a three and a half point
favorite against the bengals who won
their first playoff game in 31 years
titans have won those games by an
average of 20 and a half points they're
about to get running back derrick henry
back an all-pro running back against the
cincinnati defense that's kind of beat
up so titans look to be good there but
this young joe bro and jamar chase have
been absolutely incredible so he'll have
to have a high flying game to stay with
those titans that bye week cannot be
underestimated though you know that rest
well the other big one is is the packers
coming off the buy the other number one
seed in the nfc uh playing in a seven
o'clock game in green bay temperatures
are expected to be in the low teens and
those san francisco niners coming off
their big upset which we won't mention
um the only upset of the week right but
garoppolo hasn't played in those cold
weather sites so we'll see if the niners
can pull an upset there really quickly
as we don't have any time left where can
people go to get the app go to stn
sports or show up to any of the station
casino sports books wildfire el cortez
we'll get you signed up in less than
five minutes and have you ready to bet
all the games jason mccormick always
great having you here really appreciate
it good luck with everything this year
thanks guys mercedes